we were talking about threesomes last a
couple weeks ago rinder render yeah
is surrender an app it was you know brad
williams i do i do so that's how he met
his wife on thrinder and the third
didn't show so he married the one that
showed oh and he has an imaginary third
he's adorable he is and they have and he
has a child now is that
this i can't say it it's gonna there's
nothing you can't say okay is that a
threesome or is that a two and a half
something
i can't say that yeah you can he
brad allows that brad does allow that
he's what did he say he was the leaning
tower of pisa right yeah well that's
when in a threesome he was the it was
always to the
edge we depicted it on on the episode
with brad williams you look at it and
the lovely jeremy who is also a producer
and editor and also an amazing graphic
guy and animator so he created a sexual
and animated
sexual diagram of brad williams uh
[ __ ] audience members
no yeah audience
well that's where they were right he
talked about the audience members came
now you use that word as a verb with
your daughter does it make you
uncomfortable or does it make you know
without that word she would not be here
true yeah what did we say today we're
not using the word no we didn't want to
use the f words
i'm not using it your daughter is here
the c word charge it
let's see it by the way you got a smart
son he's technical why is the guest
camera over there if i'm looking at you
okay alex alex seen like i mean howard
stern the camera would be right there
yeah alex why is not the camera here
alex why is not we actually didn't
originally set up the cameras uh someone
else did oh so that's it you inherited
the cameras from another setup
no but why wouldn't but wait wait alex
why didn't you move it when you
inherited it would you like me to move
it right now i think bob i would love it
yeah you don't have to shot it's like
spielberg shows up it goes like the
cameras were here i can't move yeah get
in here alex and set it up we can have
the whole movie it's it's about the the
cables that were set up we didn't really
have the reach for them but that's just
an excuse i don't go to radio shack and
get a cable i see you don't have a cable
i see some of these cables are very
cheaply bought they are they're thin
cables they were here from other people
oh so what was here was it a strip club
this room yeah
this was the back room i don't know this
was uh what did we do with this
what was here why here he is alex is
gonna
alex do you think you have the cable
limbs oh there's uh
there's brad williams in his uh
threesome with the uh the other eiffel
towers are uh depictions of the audience
members he met a a woman in the audience
or he met a guy in the audience that
said would you like to come home and do
my wife with me
that's so gross i could never do that no
no with him and then he taught me
another term the paint brush
which is do you know what that is i know
it's going to be something dirty well it
is he is because of his height is it the
mustache kind of thing where well the
dirty sanchez yeah just that no no no
but this was an accident you get dirtier
when your daughter's around
i think you're trying to prove a point
that you're one of us
no i'm not
i'm not but you brought up brad and this
is what i was
so he said because of his height when he
didn't communicate well with the other
man and they were going around to switch
sides orifices yeah they went on the
same direction and he got swiped like a
paintbrush across the face that's your
daughter saying this yeah my daughter's
almost 40. uh he's thirty
thirty seven maybe on the freeway but
this is a young woman you were about to
say before i made ever
caused a ruckus and made your son go
through a midlife crisis
trying to move a camera but
whatever now it's unplugged so you're
not even going to be on camera for about
20 minutes that's great what it has
i've always wanted to do an unplugged
special yeah how you were about to say
to do a bobsage it's in the dark it's
just
an hour of darkness
we got the generator
so you were gonna say how we met you
were gonna say when we met to your
daughter and your son who were in the
room yeah where it happened
uh and it was a long time ago i love
that you're comparing us getting
together like to play hamilton
[Laughter]
um yeah
you were playing
a bagel i was playing a bagel
deli look what you've done i've ruined
the world
look at him look how strong he got
he was we've had a guest on every this
is my this is the 40th episode
this is it this is our fourth this will
be the subheading and bob saget
rearranges the camera that will be the
ending deal or no deal alex look where
you are do you want the briefcase with
coke in it or do you want
you know what this is this is going to
help you better because jezelnik said he
couldn't even see the cameras right this
is going to help you with what they call
guests
this is because the guest doesn't want
the we had a lot of cameras i just
didn't know where to aim that well
watch the zobruder film and don't do
that
look at
the mess so i was that's fine i mean
it's cables it's electronics
okay
look at me not the camera i'm not i
haven't looked at the camera i know it
was behind you but now it's going to be
in front of you
is he right alex jacob do you have a
problem with your profile is there a
reason why i have a problem with many
angles of my face there aren't many that
i love i mean i wish i could photoshop
my existence first of all i know this
this is probably going to air in a week
or two but i'm fascinated i'm i love you
i love you you and i have some thing and
it's called my penis but the thing no
sorry i got confused it's your penis we
share
i have to ask you something i know your
daughter's here right but i've known you
forever um i mean since we were in our
early 20s yes you did you always shave
your entire body forget the the head
because you weren't at the time but the
rest of you were you shaving um
why why is he making love to bob's big
boy
you came in didn't like the camera hang
on now look at my son well that's
actually what he's doing now is that's
comedy that's actually comedy right now
because i don't see him i just see this
thing moving
upstaging everything this has gone so
smoothly it's never gone better
could you go up on the roof and change
the air system
that's hysterical
[Music]
you